ووسط هذا التصعيد المستمر لا يزال التعثر
عنوان المساعي الساعيه للتوسط من اجل وقف
اطلاق النار وتقود القاهره مساء التهدئه
التي لم تكلل بالنجاح لحد الان وفي اطار
هذه المساعي دائما وصل رئيس الدائره
السياسيه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي محمد
الهندي الى القاهره لبحث الوصول الى اتفاق
لوقف اطلاق النار وتشترط حركه الجهاد
الافراج عن تثماني خضر عدنان الذي توفي في
السجون الاسرائيليه ووقف الاغتيالات فضلا
عن الغاء مسيره الاعلام المقرره في
الثامنه عشر من مايو المقبل في القدس على
الطرف الاخر فان مطالب اسرائيل ليست واضحه
لحد الان علما ان وفدا مصريا في طريقه الى
تل ابيب ايضا لاجراء مفاوضات بشان وقف
اطلاق النار وذلك نقلا عن هيئه البث
الاسرائيلي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات